thanks and thanks the organizers for
chance to give this survey that will
outline a lot of recent progress on the
ordinary TSP and a closely related
problem the STS tsp path so probably
everyone knows what the Traveling
Salesman problem was but let me define
it for you anyway
get notation down think about given a
weighted complete graph G with cost C on
the edges and we want to find a minimum
weight minimum total cost Hamiltonian
circuit a cycle definitive is 'its every
node in the graph exactly once and
returns to the origin this is a figure
from the celebrated paper of Danzig
Fulkerson Johnson and 54 which solved
the then 48 capital problem for the u.s.
actually is 49 because they also
included DC so we're gonna be focusing
on the metric case so that is that I'm
going to assume and there are two
equivalent versions to think about that
the triangle holds on the costs so that
the shortest route between any pair of
points is the direct one or it's
equivalent to think about where I'm
allowing multiple visits to each each
vertex closer equivalent versions the
problem didn't be hard dicks original
paper and Christopher T's in 1976 gave a
three halves approximation algorithm by
a row approximation algorithm going
going to mean of an algorithm that
delivers a feasible solution runs in
polynomial time and produces a solution
of cost within a factor of Rho of
optimal okay
and that's where we still are you know
it's a few years later um and and stated
in this general way nothing better is
now but look you could say I'm done I'm
just that's the recent progress but but
there were there are a few things still
to talk about so as I mentioned I'll
also be talking about this what seems to
be closely related problem but but in
many ways is different and has given us
room for improvement the esti path TSP
and it's essentially the same thing
except I fix both a starting point s and
an end point T and now I want the
minimum cost Hamiltonian path that
exactly goes between those two that pair
of endpoints a it's all clearly also
np-hard and Hulka vain showed still not
quite as long ago but still pretty a
long time ago that the natural extension
of Christie PDS algorithm is 5/3
approximation algorithm and also did
that bound is tight so this has been
exciting times and in really from my
sense of sort of how the history of
science worked the real kick off in the
energizing event was though is a really
beautiful result of a support women's
Maggio vests Karen and suburi
which pioneered what they call the thin
tree approach and not in for either the
problems I already mentioned but for the
so called asymmetric case so I still
going to assume that there's triangle
inequality but that the distance from
Ida J can be different from the distance
from J to I and the the the key
innovator they're really in some sense
where two primary pieces of funding of
innovation in addition to the the
framework of thin trees was that as
opposed to the approaches that came out
of the original algorithms or events
Krishna theories rather than first
trying to start with a deterministic
selection of a tree and augmenting that
to something that could be traversed
well is being oil aryan the
new element here was to use
randomization that the to use a randomly
selected tree and then there was a key
role of the maximum entropy distribution
as being the mechanism by which that
random selection was done and in some
way these those two elements were then
carried over in equally exciting work by
over scarran sumerian sing not for the
full generality of the symmetric case
but for a special class of metrics so if
I give you an undirected graph and it's
unweighted and I divide the distance
between a pair of nodes to be the number
of edges in the shortest path between
that that pair of nodes that gives lies
arrives to a metric and it's clearly a
specialized one and that's what I'll
call the unit weight graphical metric
and and they shaved off literally an
epsilon or even less than that off of
the three halves again combining those
two elements in a fundamental way mum
cans fencin in a using a very different
approach in a way that sort of less
explicitly relies on in a formal
relaxation as is the sort of team of
this workshop then actually gave a very
elegant very beautiful and in some ways
more substantial improvement just
shortly thereafter it's and it's led to
a sequence of results for the esti path
and this is where I'll sort of spend
most of the time today it's actually
turned out to be relatively easy to
provide a randomized variant of crista
feeties and not even used the maximum
entropy piece two for the arbitrary
metric now not just the unit weight
graphical metric to get improvements on
the basic case and and yet there are
also are improvements on the the unit
weight case in there for a series of
analyses as well so so that was where
things stood three four years ago and
then the the things continue to
accelerate data on the in the thin tree
world that Marcus Spielman and
Srivastava fundamental groundbreaking
work was shown how to be you
the tool by Inari an NGO vez Caron and
gave the improvements for the asymmetric
TSP now interesting enough this was in
some sense a existential result it
proved improvements in the integrality
gap the ratio between the optimal energy
solution an optimal fractional solution
but it actually didn't provide an
algorithm to produce the Tor work
continued unabated on on the unit weight
graphical metric in the symmetric case
and a lot of the work there was was on
restricted classes of graphs and for
which there were improvements and on the
esti path there were a series of
refinements of vegan Gottschalk and
vegan and Chabot and Vance Allen and at
the point that the organizers asked me
to give this talk that was the were
things stood and they proved they had
proved a three halves plus one over 34
approximation algorithm so so elect you
know three percent above what in some
sense we might be hoping for but it's
still we're still not done and over just
over the summer there have been two
stunning advances the first you gets
here in the next hour so I'm not gonna
say anything about the love T we'll talk
about the first constant approximation
algorithm for the asymmetric TSP and the
tribe and vegan showed how you can build
upon the relaxations that have been used
up till now for the esti path and adding
both the sort of a kind of recursive
dynamic programming framework to show
that you can achieve arbitrarily close
to three-halves and if all goes well
I'll get to give you a flavor of how
that works as well
okay so so tremendous amount of progress
it turns into work in in a very short
span of time and really in some sense
the higher-level question is how does
randomization can help us to beat what a
straightforward Christofias algorithm is
and I'll go through things in detail but
at the highest level on the left the
deterministic standard Christopher D
says we start with a minimum spanning
tree for our inputs we try to build
connectivity we augment that
tree into a low-cost oil Arian circuit
if we're looking for a tour or a path
there and then we transform it into a
Hamiltonian circuit in contrast to that
how can we instead rather than choosing
a minimum spanning tree choose carefully
selected from a appropriate random
random distribution probability
distribution select a random tree and
this was the the approach pioneered
first by us at portal and then in the
asymmetric case and then that mobis
Garance a variance in conjectured that
for the standard Christa Feeney's
algorithm that this indeed led to a an
improvement they proved a slight
modification of that but more or less
exactly that for the unit graphical we
knew a graphical metric and and then
this is exactly the framework that we
used so probably I know this is sort of
this this mixture of continuous and
discrete so I'm gonna try to make this
completely talk completely
self-contained so although probably 99%
of you know it kristie fetuses I will
start and just walk you through from
from from from the ground up okay so
Christa PDS algorithm imagine that I'm
given a collection of points and for for
that input to the physical distance on
the screen is the cost of connecting
that pair of points we start by
computing a minimum spanning tree there
you have it and then we take advantage
of the oldest theory that wasn't quite
proved it by Euler that every graph has
an Euler Ian circuit if and only if the
graph is connected in every vertex has
an even degree in or Larian circuit
being a traversal of the graph which
visits every edge exactly once and
returns to where it starts and Christie
PDS identifies those vertices in our
graph which have the wrong parity of
degree in the
space it's the odd degree vertices those
are indicated in red and then perhaps in
a somewhat non-standard language for
many of you we find a minimal cost t
join J so T in this discussion is
actually a variable it's exactly
corresponds to the set of wrong parity
of degree nodes and it's simply a set of
edges with the property that the degree
of that set of edges is odd for each
node in T and X those are exactly the
ones about degrees so that's it for
example a tiejun for if the red notes
are that are the set T or that's a T joy
or much more simply that's a T joint and
when you have the metric case it is that
it is always the true that the minimum a
a minimum cost t join is is a matching
on the set of notes okay so so we add
that T join in this now makes because
we've corrected the parity of all the
ones that were wrong before and it's
still connected this now gives us an
Euler in graph we have an oil Arian tour
and then we can shortcut it to get a
cycle that's Christa few DS okay let's
switch to the SP path so let me just
lift from what we know sort of do
standardly for tours in the it's gonna
be the exact same algorithm okay so now
that's the same input but now I'm gonna
have to tell you what's s and what's T
let's say that those are my SMT and of
course what I now want is annoy Larry
and graph with respect to paths so now I
require that s and T have odd degree and
all the others have even degree so now
if I highlight what are the wrong parity
of degrees in from the minimum spanning
tree it is those four red nodes that s
being even is bad and the others are odd
and bad and so we find the minimum cost
T join whoops we find an oil Arian path
and we shortcut okay so so so that's
Christa P DS for ST path and as I
mentioned that the analysis that Hoka
vein gave for st path purpose was tight
its
five-thirds approximation algorithm and
this is a unit weight graphical metric
instance so the way to interpret that
this is the graph and the distance
between any pair of nodes is the number
of edges in the shortest path between
them the minimum spanning tree is really
in this context the same thing as
computing ASP at any spanning tree I
have the full flexibility of which
spanning tree to choose if I in an
perverse and choose this one then the
red nodes are the ones of bad degree and
this could be the matching and you can
see that I'm sort of taking 2/3 of the
total length in that matching and that I
actually need to use that there won't be
any short cutting that saves anything
and in contrast the fact that of course
I could just go straight from left to
right and have a Hamiltonian path of
like then so so this is tight and the
goal is to do something better ok a bit
of notation if I have a cut with a set
of nodes s I'm going to let Delta of s
denote the edges in the cut so the red
edges that I've highlighted if I have a
vector on defined on the edges of that
said for X of F will denote the sum of X
over that subset ok so and I'm going to
be using the notions of an incidence
vector so that whoops if I use Chi sub F
to indicate those the 0 1 vector which
is 1 on a fancy row otherwise ok
so one of the nice things about this
this how the support areas evolved from
my perspective sort of from an aesthetic
point of view is it's it's really been a
place where the there's been a
tremendous interplay between our
understanding of polyhedral
characterizations of the underlying
combinatorial or the related underlying
combinatorial optimization problems and
the design of algorithms and so of
course polyhedral combinatorics started
with the classic work of Edmonds
characterizing the minimum spanning tree
polytope so in effect what we're doing
is we're viewing the minimum spanning
tree as a linear programming problem
simply by taking the convex hull of
incidence vectors of every every
spanning tree in the input and the the
fundamental question of polyhedral come
in a Turkish if I give you a
geometrically defined object in this way
how do I write inequality version of the
linear program that exactly
characterizes that and Edmunds answer in
this way was that if I like script P be
the set of partitions of given vertex
and I take a particular partition S then
and I now generalize my own in Delta
notation to be the set of edges that
have endpoints in different parts not
just across two parts that I had before
then here are the constraints that we
need well every spanning tree has n
minus 1 edges so that constrain exactly
tells us that and furthermore if I think
about any K way partition in two
different parts
then the spanning tree has to connect
amongst parts so so we're gonna need at
least K minus 1 edges that are in the
cuts defined and they're between 0 1 and
Edmund says this is exactly the same
thing as the
how is this useful in terms of our
analysis that one thing that we can use
this for is that if I want to prove that
the optimal solution to the minimum
spanning tree is cheap all I have to
exhibit is a feasible solution to this
linear program because I know that the
optimal solution is achieved at a vertex
which corresponds to minimum spanning
tree so the mirror exhibiting of a
feasible potentially fractional solution
is sufficient to give an upper bound on
the quality of the solution that I want
and then therefore the name of the game
is going to be exactly producing
fractional solutions that are good
rather than necessarily integer ones and
that's going to give us a lot of
flexibility so meanwhile back to the TSP
that the standard LP relaxation for the
TSP is is as follows I have an edge I
have a variable associated with each
edge and I have two kinds of constraints
I have constraints that say that for
each vertex I have to have exactly two
edges incident to it and for each cut I
have to have at least two edges that go
across that cut now I have a feasible
solution that's integer that's 0 1 4 for
this formulation then clearly that's a
feasible tour we're going to be
considering the LP relaxation so let's
let X star and throughout this talk X
star will always denote the LP optimum
that oh that gives us a lower bound and
one thing that's that's easy to see is
that if I take any feasible solution to
this linear program and I rescale it you
know this this any feasible solution
here sort of has in total by degree
bounds fractionally totally n edges if I
rescale it by n minus 1 over N then it's
fractionally it has about n minus 1
edges it's easy to argue that this is
actually a feasible solution in the
spanning tree polytope so one thing that
we know right off the bat then is that
if I look at the cost of
but I take the the LP solution of the
optimal LP solution that rescale it then
this actually also gives me an upper
bound on the cost of the minimum
spanning tree exactly by this exhibiting
a feasible fractional solution principle
so if I'm thinking about trying to
analyze Crysta PD's algorithms from a
linear programming perspective then I
had two elements in terms of what we put
into the solution we put in a minimum
spanning tree and we put a minimum cost
T joint so I talked about the polyhedral
underlying for the spanning trees now
I'm going to need the exact Allen analog
for T joins so and this goes to classic
result of Edmondson Johnson which says
the following that now if I take a set s
and suppose that it has an odd number of
the wrong parody of degree nodes
contained within it then given that I
need to pair up each of them and they
can pair up evenly there must be one
edge that reaches across that cut so so
that says that and now I will think
about deciding which edges are in the T
joined by their a variable Y sub e this
says that across each cut for which
there is this odd cardinality
intersection with the candidate set
sometimes I'll call them odd sets that
there has to be at least one okay and
again this gives an exact
characterization of what it means to
optimize over the integer objects as
well that I can optimize over this
instead so and I'll call such a feasible
solution a fractional T joint in an
upper bound span so so we'll see observe
that although there are purely
combinatorial analyses you can get this
LP based proof simply by saying well
suppose we start out with our optimal
solution to the standard LP relaxation
and generate a vector Y by dividing each
component of that by two okay now I
claim that if you think about the fact
that for every subset the original LP
solution satisfies that it's at least
two when I divided by half for each
subset let alone just for all the odd
subsets the amount of weight going
across the cut is going to be at least
one for that rescaled vector so
so in fact why this why star is a
fractional tea join and so that of
course gives us a way of upper bounding
the cost of the optimal integer tea join
that we can compute as part of the
algorithm and this the tour that we
computed is shortcutted from the union
of the spanning tree and the tea join
the spanning tree is bounded by the
original LP the T joint is bounded by Y
star which is half so that's three half
times the LP so so this is a purely LP
based proof of the bounds of Christi PD
salvia and this you know highlights what
is in some sense always the driving
force and using the in deriving
approximation algorithms based on
relaxations is that the so called
integrality gap we know how much can we
hope to do to prove in terms of the
performance of an algorithm if we're
solely basing the performance based on
what the relaxation is so for for the
TSP what i've just shown is that the
integrality gap is at most three halves
and in fact there examples that show
that it's at least four thirds and their
conjectures dating back to the 70s we
don't really know who who really should
get credit for the conjecture might be
Cunningham it might be Seymour might be
pulley blank that there's one amongst
them all probably should be it get
credit for the conjecture that it's four
thirds
for the path case and I'll show you this
in a minute that you can do it in
Allegan upper bound of 5/3 and then
we'll make progress on that
there's an analogous lower bound of
three halves so already we see that
these problems are different this is the
worst case example for for the SP path
somehow for sort of combinatorial non
niceties of having those two endpoints
means that the LP is is already off to a
weak start so what is the LP so the LP
is very much analogous but you know it's
but it's different the four s and T we
only have degree one everything else has
degree 2 you have to be a little careful
about cuts there are two different kinds
of cuts if I only have one of my
endpoints in the set s then of course I
only need to have at least one edge
going across the cut if I have both of
my endpoints in the set or neither then
I'm still gonna need to have at least
two edges going across the cut so I end
up with constraints like that okay so
good one thing to observe is that this
is polynomial time solvable by the
ellipsoid method and there are other
ways of doing that as well and also the
not surprisingly when one thinks about
what I already told you about the
rescaled version of the tour version I
mean this a path is a spanning tree that
in fact this is contained within the
spanning tree polytope in its entirety
without any rescaling
and furthermore since its contained
within the spanning tree polytope this
means that any feasible solution can be
written as a convex combination of its
extreme points which are spanning trees
and so that we means that we can take
the optimal solution and rewrite it as
such a convex combination and in fact
gorillas love a subscriber already show
how to actually do that effectively in
polynomial time so I'm gonna need that
as a tool okay so good so so this is the
algorithm we proposed a few years ago
which I call the best of many Christa
feeties and it works as follows suppose
I start by computing the optimal
solution to that LP relaxation call that
X star and now rewrite that X star as a
convex combination
of spanning trees t13 TK and now for
each of those spanning trees run the
ordinary Christina's algorithm so just
you know take that tree free that has a
set of wrong parity of degree find the
minimum t join ji for that I wanna of
meant and short cut it to Hamiltonian
path and then you now have a collection
of all because of standard things in
palliative combinatorics we know that
they're actually a polynomial number of
such trees that we can write it as and
so we can just take the best of that
polynomial number of paths and output
that okay so that's best if Krista
feeties okay no and I've been blasting
ahead but but will you please do
interrupt with questions okay but rather
than analyze that we're going to instead
analyze a randomized version so now do
the same thing compute an optimal
solution to the held carp relaxation to
the LP relaxation and now rewrite it as
a convex combination of spanning trees
as follows
but now view that convex combination is
a probability distribution over that
subset of spanning trees and just
blithely sample according to that
distribution and just choose one sample
so choose TI with probability lambda I
and now extend that spanning tree by
Krishna standard Krishna P DS okay so
that's the algorithm I want to analyze
one obvious thing is the relationship
between the two exhibit a gorilla's the
numeron of one and the random one if I
can show that the expected cost of the
random one is bounded by Rho times the
optimal value that and now of course
that expectation is computed just solely
over the random is a random choice of
spanning trees then of course the
algorithm that tries each and every one
of them has to do no worse than then
taking the best of that that average
okay so so that's this randomized
analysis is a mechanism for proving a
bound on the deterministic
with them one easy next step I mean if I
if you think about what the convex
combination means and think about what's
the probability that the random tree
contains a particular edge well it's
just the weight that it occurs in total
over that distribution of the of-of-of
trees it exactly sums because it's a
convex combination to the the original
LP value so that says the probability of
an edge being in there is exactly the
original LP value that we started with
and so the expected cost of the spanning
tree that we produce by linearity of
expectation is of course exactly the LP
value that we objective function value
that we started with so if you think
about what we just did of replacing a
minimum spanning tree by this random
selection we haven't lost that well we
have we might have lost something we
might have gotten more expensive object
but our ability to bound that tree by
the optimal value is still intact
because it's bounded above by the the LP
value okay so so so all we have to do is
now wonder about now we have a random
tree which gives rise to a random set of
wrong parity of degree nodes and
therefore we're going to compute a
optimal T join for that random set and
we want to be able to bound the
expectation of the minimum cost that
we're going to need okay and that's all
gonna need to focus on so so if I'm
gonna prove let's just even start with
as a baseline with the 5/3 if I'm gonna
prove a Thirds bound on the cost of the
T joint again I'm gonna do it by
exhibiting a fractional solution to the
LP relaxation it must have expected
value that's no more than 2/3 times the
LP value that's the goal here okay and
just again notation this has been our
optimal LP value and then of course this
is going to be the incidence vector of
the spanning tree that we selected at
random now sort of if you lift back sort
of analyses that you know and love one
thing that you can think about is so we
just saw that Krista feeties algorithm
now we can be interpreted as using half
of the LP solution as the fractional T
joint and we also know you know thinking
back to the or
Neri TSP case and the Doubletree
algorithm that it's also standard to
think about using the spanning tree
itself as a fractional tea joint so one
thing that we now can do is think about
taking a fraction of the two vectors
where the total weight on the two vector
sums to two-thirds if I can do that
then I'll get exactly what I want that
so that's the goal okay so so so that's
what we want to do everybody with me
now of course individually life is just
bad if I want that just beta times X
star to be a fractional tea join if you
think about what's happening before
whereas in the Tor case we could divide
by two and have that to come bound to be
at least one or four the path case we
have lots of these cuts that are only
going to be at least one if I rescale by
any amount all of a sudden I'm gonna
start violating those so so that's
that's not looking promising now
similarly what about the incidence
vector to the tree I mean one thing one
knows about tree is of course every cut
there's at least one edge going across
but again I don't have any room to spare
it seems I mean I'd like to have maybe
two edges going across and that's
exactly where we're doing so so because
of course I'm gonna need for my
fractional tea join solution I'm gonna
need that at least one for each table
cut so here's the lemma that drives
everything it's trivial it has it even a
trivial proof maybe I'll do it just to
prove to you that it's trivial that but
here's the here's the result I take any
spanning tree I take any cut that
separates s and T those are the ones
where I have the constraint that there's
only at least one in my LP solution
going across
and it's an odd cut so it means that I
have I have an odd number of wrong
parody of degree nodes within that claim
there at least 2 edges and the spanning
tree that go across the cut magic ok not
magic easy counting argument okay let's
do the counting so like right here this
is this is an example that this is a
wrong parody degree that's wrong parent
agree that's wrong they're two edges
that go across the cut okay so what I'm
really gonna do is I'm going to show
they're an even number of edges to go
across the cut and since it's a spanning
tree there has to be at least one and
it's one and it's elite even it has to
be at least two okay so here's the
counting ironin count the total degree
of nodes in you so what does that do
that contribute for every edge that goes
across the cut we count that once but
every edge that's within within you we
count that twice so I can rewrite that
as that the the edges that go across the
cut is the sum of the total degree minus
two times the number of edges within I
just moved that sum of over to the other
side but this says that this is a number
of edges in the cut there so if I show
you that there an even number of odd
degree nodes in you then this is gonna
be even so let me do that that's easy
well this was an odd cut too they're an
odd number of wrong degree nodes so
either s is even and then the number of
odd nodes are is is even or s is odd
it's not wrong and then we balance out
the other way so I'm done so and this is
everything this is this is what's going
to drive out at least 50% of the work to
go
good okay so so we know if I look at the
spanning tree that there are at least
two edges that go across the the cut for
the T and since vector but only 1/4 for
the LP on the other hand for the non
separating cuts then we know that the LP
gives us 2 but the the L but but the
incidence vector of the tree only gives
us 1 so it's pretty easy to figure out
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna wait each
with 1/3 like so we're going to take
that Alpha and the beta both equal to
1/3 and when we add them up then we're
gonna get at least 1 in terms of
fractional weight going across because
remember all I need to do is to exhibit
a fractional solution that was feasible
that had good cost and and and I'm in
business ok so so so that's my feasible
fractional solution to my t joint
polytope and away I go and and the
analysis who cost us just as
straightforward that I need to analyze
the cost of y which is really just the
expected cost of the insert alpha times
the incidence vector plus beta times the
LP and we know separately that we we can
just add up then the results as follows
okay so so we can in general and this is
you know I took alpha plus beta so as to
guarantee feasibility in one third one
third but in general when no matter what
I get if I you know take alpha times
this and beta times that I'm gonna end
up with a 1 plus alpha plus beta
approximation algorithm okay next step
and actually you could have although I
analyzed this other problem you actually
could use it more or less the same
original algorithm to get an LP based
yes idea okay so that worked to get us
five thirds so now I'm gonna take alpha
and beta and I'm gonna just perturb it
them slightly I'm gonna decrease the
wait on alpha on the the tree part by
two epsilon and increase the weight on
on the LP solution by Epsilon okay so
what happens there well if I look at
what happens for the non separating cuts
we're decreasing this by two epsilon and
we're increasing that by Epsilon but it
gets multiplied by two so the net
perturbation is a wash and so we're
still satisfying those constraints on
the other hand for the ST cuts life
could be bad no this goes down by two
epsilon this goes up by Epsilon the net
result is that we could go down by three
epsilon over what we're satisfied and
all of a sudden no longer achieving at
least one we're achieving at least one
minus three epsilon the sitter of a
deficiency that that's creeping in in
terms of what how much weight I'm
putting across some of the cuts that I
need to satisfy and so so so but but
it's but it's a small deficiency but if
I only think about this a small
perturbation it's only missing by a
little bit and what happens to the cost
well that's good right because the cost
I mean this goes down by two epsilon
this goes up by epsilon that the overall
net effect on the cost is gonna need to
go down so so if I can make this work
and it's going to go down proportional
to Epsilon
so if I had any slack in my st cuts to
start with you know if it wasn't exactly
one that that that perturbation will be
fine so with that in mind I'll define a
town narrow cut is to sort of give you a
sense of how much slack there is in that
constraint so so for it's an ST cut just
any ST cut with the property that the
total weight that goes at is less than 1
plus tau okay so those are the ones that
are in danger by this perturbation
so one thing you might start worrying
about is well I might have some cuts
that are already at one and even just
the slightest perturbation is going to
violate it and actually one can prove in
sort of a corollary that that previous
lemma by a kind of averaging argument
that in fact any cut that has LP weighed
exactly one can't be odd and the reason
is that you're really what that LP
weight is and that is an average weight
over spanning trees and since each
spanning tree always has weight of one
going across it if you if you go a
little under than then you must maybe if
you get exactly one you must be hitting
it with exactly one every time similarly
you can argue whoops I didn't want to do
that that if you look at how much slack
I have if you look at a town arrow cut
the probability that that is odd is
bounded by tau so the previous case is
just a special case so what I had said
before
and that has a again relying proof not
hard so what have we got we've got sort
of non separating cuts and the ST cuts
you know they're they're good as I do
the the SD cuts that sort of our have
some slack in it they're good if I do
this little perturbation and things
violation happens with probabilities
smaller than something that's order
epsilon in terms of there and when this
happens the cut will have sort of
deficiency that's proportional to
epsilon okay just tiny so let's just
fantasize that the sets of tau narrow
cuts were actually disjoint sets so that
if I looked at those edge sets from all
the different town arrow cuts that they
just hit different edges well I claim
that what I can do then is take my
original alpha plus beta which has now
been perturbed a little bit and just
boost it a little bit by some small
amount and how much amount well just you
know the deficiency for any edge that
happens to appear in one of those cuts
so if it's in one of those turn arrow
cuts you know just just put that
deficiency which was sort of slowed up
and only do it when it's odd and now I
need to compute the expectation of you
know how much I'm putting in and there's
sort of this probabilistic element that
I'm only adding in this cost when it's
odd and that happens rarely and in
itself not doing and so first of all
it's clear that this is a fractional T
joint and it's also straight for me
essentially the analysis I just gave you
says that the expected cost of this
little extra boost is you know no more
than the deficiency times tau times the
original LP cost and notice this is like
o of epsilon and this is like o of
Epsilon so this is like some o of
epsilon squared times the LP value and I
already argued that the change of the LP
cost improved by this perturbation by
something that was order epsilon times
the LP value so now it's just a question
of balancing the constants right that
you sort of see that hey
that if this all works out then then we
should be able to get some improvements
another language of saying this is to
write out this correction vector a
little bit more explicitly this way and
and and and so if our fantasy were true
if you work out the balancing we get
some slight improvements on that five
three it's not a huge improvement Lane
one point six five and that's all still
based on this fantasy which isn't true
so they're not disjoint so now I'm going
to kind of get to the next key element
of from an idea perspective which is
they're not disjoint but they're highly
structured they form a laminar family I
mean not even a laminar for a nested
family that if I look at the the set of
Perun arrow cuts and then then I have
this additional property I was hoping to
do the proof it's two lines but I won't
okay I mean so it is a standard on
crossing argument so this means that I
have this nice structure as I look at
some here's some fractional solution and
here are the outer bounds if you will of
the cuts that are in this case one
narrow and so the cuts are not disjoint
if you look at it here let's say that if
I look at the edges that cross from here
over to the left this edges in it but
it's also in this town arrow cut so what
I can do instead is say for this cut I'm
going to select those edges that start
exactly in that outer layer and only in
that outer layer so the ones that are
involved I'm selecting that and now as a
result I'm just apportioning those cuts
and so what then can argue is that we
actually are getting most of the weight
that crosses that cut by making this
selection and then that and that most is
again a 1 minus tau so again something 1
- lets order Epsilon
in terms of how much weight that that
where we're saving and so what that
means is that rather than boosting
things that the the deficiency x times
the incidence quantity we have to sort
of rescale by this one over one minus
Epsilon kind of kind of thing but it so
it slightly perturbs the the overall
balancing but all is said and done we
still end up slightly under two thirds
okay so so that's we broken five thirds
and indeed if you add some bells and
whistles to the analysis I gave you good
we originally went down all the way to
the golden ratio and reshef who came
along and gave us somewhat better
analysis and got it down to one point
six she's wrong
Gao gave a unified analysis which is
really very elegance that got it gave a
unified proof for the two results so now
I want to switch gears
five minutes beyond where I wanted to do
and go back to the unit weight graphical
case so and what I wanted so so by now
for the esti path Sheva and vegan
actually met the LP integrality gap with
a combinatorial algorithm and Gao gave a
very simple combinatorial algorithm a
simple LP based algorithm and I'm going
able to view the whole proof in the next
five minutes so really clean and elegant
so so we need to sort of rethink things
a bit because of its the unit weight
graphical case
what's really happening in thinking
about the interplay of t joins and
augmenting a minimum spanning tree is
we're taking multiple copies of an edge
so as to create an oil Arian graph and
really what the cost metric that we're
bounding is just the number of total
edges that we get and because what we
care about is being connected and and
and and being oil Arian even degree or
parity of degree there's no point in
making more than two copies of any given
edge because if there are three copies
one would suffice just the same so so
now we use that to write an LP which
just says the number of copies and I'll
show you in the next slide but it's the
standard version you know very natural
LP and the way the algorithm works is we
solve the LP and we use this it's which
is a different framing but has all the
same structural properties that we
already talked about in the previous one
so again I can look at all of the narrow
cuts that get generated when I solve
that LP the esti cuts that that are
under - in terms of the total weight and
that there have this nice layered
structure and the algorithm works as
follows that between each layer we just
choose the cheapest just choose one edge
that goes across that from-from layer L
I to Li plus one and within each layer
we just choose a spanning tree and now
we build together a bigger spanning tree
and the claim is that now we actually
can go back to the original Woolsey
proof and just take the LP solution and
divide it by two and that's gonna be a
feasible fractional tea joint so there
are a number of things that I need to
prove that most importantly I need to
prove that the algorithm makes sense
that there actually if I look at the
support of the LP solution that we
actually can get us a spanning tree in
each layer and that there is an edge
that connects between any given layers
that so I can actually construct that
that spanning tree but in some sense
this is just a the old algorithm just a
particular choice of which spanning tree
that we
seem so fun so this is the LP not a big
surprise that it's each edges between 0
and 2 we have cut constraints that go
across and that we have the partition
constraints ok so let this be the chain
of one narrow cuts and let Li be the
incremental layer just as we we had
analogously and consider the support
graph of the LP solution and the claim
is that if I take some number of layers
that are consecutive that if I look at
the union of that and look in just in
the support graph that that that's a
connected graph so so this is a will do
as follows and and I'll take one case
it's really the hardest case so so
here's my whole graph and here we have
some number of layers and let's take
some layers so he s is in here and T is
in here and let's say we take J and K
separated a bit and what I need to do is
I need to prove that the graph induced
by the LP solution on these layers is
connected so we have sort of four parts
to our graph let's say it's not
connected that means there's a cut so we
have let's call this s 0 let's call this
s 1 let's call this s 2 and let's call
this s 3
so what do I know well
we know that s1 and s2 are cuts the
don't contain either S or T those are my
Easi LP constraints that say they have
at least way to going across that cut so
we have for each of those we have wait
at least two on the other hand s 0 and s
3 were defined to be one narrow so that
means they have weighed strictly both
less than two but now one can think
about if I take any edge that leaves
let's say s 1 but symmetrically s 2 it
must go either to s 0 or 2 s 3 because I
mean we defined them because these were
not connected so that means that the
total weight in s 1 and s 2 is bounded
from above by the total weight in s 0
plus s 3 but s 0 plus s 3 were less than
4 in total and s 1 plus s 2 were at
least 4 in total and one of those
inequalities was strict so we have a
contradiction and therefore it must be
connected
good
so the next thing I need to argue is
that I actually get a fractional tea
join where that's the wrong parity of
degree and so suppose there is a
violated set where it's an odd set well
we know it has to be an ST cut it has to
be one narrow by definition of
narrowness and now that by the
construction the number of tree edges
crossing each narrow cut is exactly 1 we
just built it that way but remember our
key lemma the key lemma says take any
spanning tree and the wrong you know the
the number of edges crossing any odd cut
for any odd set has to be even or has to
be at least two so none of those could
be odd sets so indeed the only places I
have one I'm golden
so so this is a feasible fractional T
joint so in fact this analysis had
nothing to do with the unit weight case
other than we could construct such a
cheap tree and the goal for all the work
that ensued was somehow to take these
structural properties and lift those
ideas to general metrics so
I the natural thing would have been to
take and say well suppose I just used
took the minimum cost edge across each
layer and the narrow cut and I took a
minimum spanning tree
well GAO's showed that those can be bad
so that they're examples for weights
there but there are there's sort of
glimmers hope so in some sense the
rescaling algorithm in the argument that
I showed earlier really showed that for
every one narrow cut and for any convex
combination of X star in two stars that
that you know if I look at that one cut
there's there's a good fraction of the
weight of the trees that are on that
that have a unique edge in that cut and
somehow what Gao is showing is that this
property of having unique edges across
these targeted cuts is exactly the key
to making progress and that's what now
get called Gao trees that that that have
this additional special property and so
God Chuck and vegan showed that there
existed a representation now that this
mean what we use was for any convex
combination they show that there's this
particular convex combination of
spanning trees such that if I take any
Thao the total weight of trees that have
a unique intersection would now with
every tower narrow cuts the what we're
gonna move so that I'll be able to get
feasibility across is at least 1 minus
tau so there's a good weight that it's
gets gets put there and that allows them
to rebalance all the rebalancing games
and get an improved guarantee
and what they get down to by now is one
point five six six we're making progress
one side notes that their algorithm had
to do all kinds of klutzy rounding in
order to actually produce this convex
company I mean that's one thing to show
that there exists such a decomposition
in fact HoloCam chair boot traveling
butts Allen recently gave us strongly
polynomial matric based algorithm to
prove to compute this decomposition
nicely chevron pants Allen built upon
all of the machinery to date and got
down to one half plus one over 34 so
another 3% improvements and and the the
new idea was sort of actually the first
time and this is I mean always attention
in in TSP approximation algorithms is we
tend to always keep everything we put
into the solution and never throw
anything away so mum gets ensign is the
great counter example to that where a
progress was made by doing both
additions and deletions and and Shepherd
and pencil and do that to they delete
some of these edges that are unique
intersections with one narrow cut in a
very delicate and careful way so as to
make further progress but I want to
spend the last few minutes giving you a
hint of the progress that came this
summer which was due to travel and vegan
to get down to three halves plus an
epsilon so one thing to realize is that
okay I'll draw another more or less
symmetric identical copy of the same
thing
so one two
eight and let's say that let's look at
what my optimal ST path looks like let's
just as whoops
yeah let's go back there
oops one more keep going
well it works okay good
I can't count so so one thing to observe
about I mean these are my one narrow
cuts and one thing to observe about any
ST path is of course that its
intersection with every cut is going to
be odd so it's either going to be one or
at least three the ones we sort of know
are good that that that they're the
crucial elements for our GAO trees so
which cuts are good and which edges span
them so this edge is the unique one
spanning this cut this edge is the
unique one spanning that cut and I
actually have two more maybe I'm gonna
get rid of this okay now I won't I'll be
good I won't cheat so two more so so
this is the unique edge
now let me cheat so there we go and this
is the unique edge spending that so so
these are the lonely edges and these are
cuts that have this unique edge property
and the first element of of the child
vegan idea is to say well this gives me
if someone told me just which were the
successive lonely no lonely Cubs then
this gives me a decomposition into
subproblems and because this is the esti
path this is really like saying well I
go from s 0 to t 0 and I go from whoops
no that's s 0 to t 0 t 0 there's sort of
a trivial problem we go from s 1 to T 1
and we go from this to 2t 2 and again
another trivial problem so we have this
decomposition into smaller st paths tsps
but there aren't so many of the kinds of
ways this decomposition can be done if I
want to just specify this as sort of
being the state of a dynamic program
then really I just have to tell you what
are the names of these edges and they're
only n of these cuts what are the cuts
that are in succession so if I
recursively somehow had something good
or I just iteratively had something good
for each of those sub pieces I could
figure out what's the best piecing
together in a standard dynamic
programming kind of methodology so I
need to find a good solution for each
and then build them back up together and
in fact one level of this isn't
sufficient that that they need a
constant level of recursions and in fact
that's how the the where the epsilon
comes from and that it's really
depending on how many levels of
recursion and clearly given the nature
of it being a large state space I can
only do a constant number of levels of
recursion what's the advantage of
getting down to a subproblem well for
all of these other cuts now rather than
just knowing that that there's at least
one going crossed I know that within the
subproblem if I've gotten the specific
line there has to be a wait at least
three and so that gives me a way of
strengthening and if I think about what
I do in rescaling that that gives me a
dish additional flexibility that I can
use a higher multiplier and then
rebalance things until notice that
actually for this help you we've now
omitted the
this is this is this is so so they're
gonna have to resolve and yes you're
gonna have to worry about whether narrow
cuts for your new version or it's the
same as the narrow cuts for the higher
level there's a lot of good German
engineering underneath the hood but but
but it's but but yeah that's and when
all is said and done you end up with the
ability to get arbitrarily close to 1.5
i guess correctly the question does this
imply the suitability for the original
thing it does not imply and in some
sense it is a masterwork of turbine
engineering but but it's certainly know
from my own I'll put my opinion flat out
there it's not the right answer
because I really believe that the
integrality gap is three halves and
there should be a solution that just
goes at it cleanly and combinatorially
without that so so yeah that's ship
advanced alan is the best so so i mean
there are a number of higher-level
issues that i should just blast through
I mean sampling Krista Fiji's gives you
all kinds of power one question is
what's the right distribution to sample
from we've seen the Gottschalk and vegan
way we had the max upon entry entropy
way there was some really elegant
computational work that Genova and and
williamson did that really showed that
the max entropy distribution produces
random trees that look very different
from from from what you'd otherwise say
it's very sort of branching and and and
and and to the like I mean very long
strands not very bushy I mean it's also
to the meta questions I mean this is a
domain where randomization was natural
and there are lots of domains where
randomization is getting used it would
be nice to have good analyses of that
and then of course given the the
surprising new results it would be nice
to understand whether this kind of
recursive dynamic programming idea would
be useful in other settings
but you've come back to where we started
as any good talk on the TSP should oh
that we still don't know anything better
in Christie PDS for the tsp and that
clearly is the open question the one
thing that might be different is this
sense of that maybe we have the
algorithm maybe max up in entropy
distribution and random sampling does it
for us we just can't prove it so maybe
there is progress
that's just bro
[Applause]
exhausting
[Applause]